bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france on allait montrer
des images on les verra tout à l'heure
des images de nice où il ya eu un
rassemblement et envoyer les gens pas
forcément respectueux de ses gestes
barrière est ce que c'est un risque
selon vous alors effectivement on va
dire depuis quelques jours on a noté une
augmentation du nombre de nouveaux cas
d'infection par le coronavirus en
métropole notamment dans certains
départements comme la mayenne et
effectivement les mesures barrières au
sein desquels la distanciation social
est très très importante permettre de
prévenir efficacement la diffusion du
virus
donc si on maintient une distance de un
mètre entre deux personnes on évite
d'être contaminé par le virus et
lorsqu'on est dans un endroit on ne peut
pas maintenir cette distance il convient
de mettre un masque afin d'éviter la
contamination
or justement avant de parler de lui
pardonne du masque est ce que vous
pensez que les autorités en font assez
pour inciter les français justement à
respecter ces gestes barrières oui alors
tout à fait on va dire les autorités
répètent le message et l'importance des
gestes barrières avec un certain nombre
d'éléments pédagogique pour pouvoir bien
utiliser le masque mais à l'évidence il
y a un certain relâchement
d'où le fait que l'eau n'est demandé de
rendre obligatoire le port du masque
dans les lieux clos public c'est à dire
dans les endroits où il ya le plus fort
risque de transmission du virus
lorsqu'il ya un rassemblement de
personnes qui ne se connaissent pas avec
un brassage important avec un contact
étroit parfois prolongées sans
possibilité de maintenir la
distanciation sociale c'est dans ces
endroits là comme d'ailleurs typiquement
dans les transports en commun qu'ils
foutent mettre le masque ans lorsque le
masque il est rendu obligatoire comme
dans les transports en commun cette
mesure est respectée ce qui n'est pas le
cas de façon uniforme dans les autres
lieux publics
pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut une tribune
justement pour rendre ce port du masque
obligatoire dans les lieux clos comme
c'est le cas dans les transports
pourquoi est ce que ce n'est ce n'est
pas déjà une recommandation une
obligation de la part des autorités du
gouvernement alors jusque là ça n'était
pas une obligation la seule obligation
concerné les transports en commun c'est
à dire les métros les trains mais il n'y
avait pas d'obligation dans dans les
lieux publics comme les les magasins les
supermarchés les cinémas etc
alors on comptait beaucoup très
probablement sur l'autodiscipline et la
responsabilisation individuelle mais il
semble qu'avec le beau temps avec
l'éloignement de la première vague
il y ait un tout petit peu d'oubli de
ces mesures d'où le fait de faire cette
recommandation assez précocement car
c'est maintenant qu'il faut que ces
habitudes rentrer en pratique
en septembre ça sera trop tard on sera
au pied d'une éventuelle deuxième vague
et là ça sera trop tard si on n'a pas de
déjà inclus ces procédures dans notre
vie quotidienne
il faut respecter les gestes barrière
portaient le masque et les tests alors
est-ce que ça aussi c'est une
recommandation que vous soulignez alors
tout à fait effectivement alors cette
recommandation est bien appliquée donc
effectivement c'est le fameux triptyque
c'est à dire en fait il faut tester
identifier les porteurs du virus
notamment les sujets asymptomatiques
afin de les isoler et protéger les
personnes vulnérables c'est-à-dire les
personnes âgées avec des comorbidités
pour éviter qu'elles saint fé que ne
développent des formes graves de la
maladie
donc ce triptyque évidemment et la
stratégie principale
développé par les autorités sanitaires
et le masque contribue justement à
préserver les choses et à prévenir
l'extension de l'épidémie
à ce stade un peu partout dans le
territoire le virus circule de façon
très faible et seul le moyen les moyens
de prévention permettent d'éviter d'en
arriver à une situation
plus sérieux et pourtant -22 20 % des
français qui ont des symptômes vont se
faire attester
oui tout à fait alors on va dire c'est
peut-être suffisant en fait ce qu'il
faut c'est tester systématiquement les
personnes contactent de sujets porteurs
al'inverse dans des dans des
départements ou dans des endroits où il
y à un cluster qui semble peu contrôlées
là il faut procéder à un dépistage plus
large de la population et c'est ce qui
est c'est ce qui va débuter en mayenne
la semaine prochaine alors on il ya
évidemment la question de voir une
seconde vague épidémique dans l'hexagone
avec ces nouveaux cluster notamment en
mayenne votre avis là-dessus
oui alors on va dire un peu partout il
existe des clusters ça n'est pas
spécifique de la mayenne
néanmoins ces clusters sont identifiés
alors essentiellement dans des
établissements d'hébergement social dans
des hôpitaux dans des ehpad dans
certains types d'industries comme les
abattoirs rapidement des mesures sont
prises pour circonscrire ces foyers et
éviter que le virus ne se répande dans
la population dans la communauté
communauté autour de ce foyer
alors il semble qu'en mayenne les
quelques foyers qui ont été identifiées
n'ont pas été suffisamment contrôlés et
que le nombre de nouveaux cas est
augmenté de façon importante est
alarmante qui failli prendre des mesures
plus importantes dont le dépistage de
masse car l'étape ultérieure serait bien
sûr un confinement ciblé deux sets de ce
département
merci à vous renommer guardian rappelle
que vous êtes le chef du service de
réanimation de l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris xi